[Musique]
ce jeudi 30 mars le groupe musical les
voix des vins en flammes et le théâtre
de champ fleuri
le quatuor de chanteuse a souhaité
proposer un concert spécial à
destination des publics en situation de
handicap
en fait c'est vraiment un plaisir
d'avoir uniquement ce public là parce
qu'il ya une
c'est quelque chose qui passe ils ont
ils ont une écoute vraiment particulière
et pour nous c'est vraiment chouette un
choix de partage avec c'est vrai la
rigueur qu'importe le public c'est
qu'ils soient attentifs à ce qu'on fait
que ça leur plaise et là on a senti une
idéologie et une spontanéité qu'on
ressent pas habituellement pour un
public voilà autre qui peut être plus
réservé et là on sent que au niveau des
émotions et de l'affectif voyez il se
lâche pour les théâtres départementaux
établissements culturels du département
il est important de proposer aux
personnes porteuses de handicap
une programmation qui leur est
entièrement consacré mais aussi
d'adapter la scène afin de leur offrir
un moment privilégié le type d'affaires
en plus c'est que ma part du principe
que souvent on dit que les personnes en
situation de handicap sont à part non
nous on s'est dit on va mettre tout le
monde sur le même niveau et le même
niveau ça veut dire mettre tout le monde
sur le plateau c'est à dire tout le
monde est sur la scène du théâtre de
champ fleuri donc au même niveau que les
artistes et comme ça ils peuvent aussi
sentir la vibration de la musique et
ressentir au plus près ce que les
artistes ont envie de donner un
spectacle qui a enchanté le public qui
n'a pas hésité à participer
maniable et danser madame o ils ont les
d'un petit qui danse bien qui s'offrent
voilà sans problème
qui sont très professionnels les
lyonnais moi j'aime et je vais pour les
chanter en dehors des programmations
spéciales un accueil adapté réservé aux
personnes porteuses de handicap avec des
accès aux fauteuils roulants pour les
théâtres départementaux il est important
que la culture soit accessible à tous
[Musique]